What if Okay. And what about the
believers who don't live morally? What's
going to happen to those?
>> Number one, you've been influenced by a
certain type of Christianity.
>> Yes, I I
>> it is. It doesn't matter how you live
because Jesus paid it all, which is
true. But that is not the Christianity
taught in scriptures or historically.
Because if you read the scriptures and
if you look at the church historically
throughout the ages,
you'll find an insistence that if you've
been purchased by Christ, you've been
bought by Christ, you die to yourself,
you die to your fleshly desires, you die
to the world because you now belong to
another and he is your Lord and you must
obey him otherwise you'll be cut off. So
that is not biblical Christianity nor is
it the historic teaching of the church.
So this is what we call easy belieism
which I used to believe but no longer
because it's not in scripture and it's
not something the church has affirmed
throughout the ages. Now mentioning the
church because it's the church whom God
used to preserve those scriptures. So
that's not a true statement that hey
morality plays no role. No, the Bible
tells you and the Lord tells you that if
you keep persisting in your rebellion
and you don't heed the conviction of the
spirit to acknowledge your sin and
repent, then there will be a time in
which God will cut you off. But that's
something known to God alone. That's
when now you've reached a level where
you've so grieved the spirit, angered
the spirit, blaspheing the spirit. Now
you're cut off. You're handed over. But
that's the time known to God. In other
words, I cannot make that judgment call.
But some of the signs that you've
reached that point is when you reach
that point, you could care less about
God. You could care less about the
Bible. You could care less about Christ.
The Bible means nothing to you. God's
teaching means nothing to you. And Jesus
was a failure. That's when you know
you've reached the point now you're dead
to God completely and it's over for you.
So that's not a true statement. The Lord
tells you he's going to judge you by
your obedience or lack thereof. Here it
is.
>> So that's the that's to begin with.
Matthew 7 23-23. Here just to give you
one of many right here it goes. That's
to begin with just to start with and
I'll answer it more deeply. Matthew
7:123. Not everyone who says to me Lord
Lord will enter the kingdom of heaven.
Right there. But he who does the love of
my father who's in heaven will enter.
Many will say to me on that day, Lord,
Lord, in your name did we not prophesy
and your name cast out demons and your
name do miracles? See, we acknowledge
you. We believed in you. We did miracles
in your name. But here's the key. And
then I will declare to them, I never
knew you. Depart from me, you who
practice lawlessness. See, that was the
key. You didn't do what I told you to
do. So, you're fake. So, who told you
obedience to God's teaching is not
necessary and essential and crucial?
Um, no one told me that, but I just I
have been seeing over and over again
Christians like um repeating the same
thing which is like I'm free to do
whatever I want because like Jesus paid
for it
>> and I don't believe that's true. I
actually I'm like going I'm sorry what?
>> No, that's what I'm saying. They told
you these Bible perverts. That's why who
told you? You've been listening to the
wrong crowd. I have I have been
listening to all sort of crowds honestly
because I'm I'm like trying to learn
more and that comes with like price to
pay which is like you expose yourself to
a lot of heretics and a lot of really
weird stuff.
>> Yep.
>> Well, here another passage Romans 6:16
to 23. Do you not know that when you go
on presenting yourselves to someone as
slaves for obedience, you're slaves of
the one whom you obey, either of sin
leading to death or of obedience leading
to righteousness? Right there. You're
either a slave to sin and you're going
to die or you're a slave to God and obey
him and you're going to live. But thanks
be to God that though you were slaves of
sin, you obeyed
from the heart that pattern of teaching
to you were given over. So when we
taught you, you obey it because you've
been set free from slavery to sin. But
you've now been made a slave of God. and
having been been freed from sin, you
became slaves of righteousness. I'm
speaking in human terms because of the
weakness of your flesh. You're too
immature to understand the deeper
things. So, I'm going to step it down to
your level. That's what he's saying. For
just as you presented your members as
slaves to impurity and to lawlessness,
leading to further lawlessness, you
lived like a heathen, and you kept
indulging your flesh, going from bad to
worse. So now present your members as
slaves to righteousness leading to
sanctification.
Now you are slave to God's moral
teachings so that the more you obey, the
holier you become, the more pure you
become. Because there's going to be a
warning. For when you were slaves of
sin, you were free in regard to
righteousness. Meaning when you lived
for your flesh, you could care less
about holiness and righteousness and
purity. You didn't even care. You went
and got drunk, got high, slept around.
Therefore, what benefit were you then
having from the things of which you are
now ashamed? Isn't it true we now look
back at our previous life and were
ashamed of it?
>> Yeah.
>> In case of those who lived immorally,
you ask the people here, those who went
to nightclubs and got drunk or got high
and slept around, now they look about it
at it say, "Damn, I'm so ashamed of what
I did." Especially women. This more so
it's a stigma for women. Women who lived
immorally and now came under conviction,
they're ashamed of their past and wish
they could erase it. And that's what
Paul is saying. Well, why are you
ashamed? Because when the spirit
convicted you, you agreed with the
spirit, you submitted to the spirit, and
now with the spirit, you agree those
things were awful, shameful, and those
things would have brought you death. But
now watch. But now having been freed
from sin and enslaved to God.
So you're not free. You're a slave to
God. You have your benefit leading to
sanctification. Sanctity means that
you'll be set apart to be holy. And if
you continue, the end is you'll have
eternal life. For the wages of sin is
death, but the gracious gift of God is
eternal life in Christ Jesus our Lord.
So that's number one.
>> First response, part of the answer.
Whoever tells you it doesn't matter what
you do. They have no idea what the hell
they're talking about. This is the
poison of what's called easy belieism.
Jesus paid it all. Doesn't matter what
you do. And Jesus says, "You're a liar.
I
>> so famous."
>> Yeah. It's dominant in America. I pay to
release you from bondage to make you my
slave. In other words, you are a slave.
He then ransomed you by his blood,
saying, "You're no longer a slave of
him. You're now a slave of me. You're my
property. But I'm a good master who
wants the best for you and know what's
best for you. So my commands are meant
for your good. Whereas your previous
master didn't care for you and wanted
evil for you and wanted to destroy you
and damn you to hell." So that's a
message of the gospel, right?
>> Yeah. Okay, you with me so far?
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> The second reason why you obey, the
Bible says Christ is the husband, the
church is the bride. If you truly love
your husband and you truly understand
the price he paid, right?
And he went out of his way to not only
tell you he loves you, but shows you he
loves you. And he died for you in order
to protect you.
Then the response of a good spouse is to
reciprocate, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Because the Bible says the church is the
bride of Christ. And I'm gonna give you
an example from everyday relationship
because this is the example the Lord
sets forth. And I'm even going to show
you in Ezekiel 23, which is very
hard-hitting and it's a knife in the
heart. Okay? You are married and the man
tells you he loves you but ignores you,
doesn't spend time with you, is always
out and then you find out he's whoring
around. Only comes when he wants to
sleep with you or only comes when you
can cook his food, wash his clothes,
vacuum his house. Does he really love
you?
>> No.
>> And if he keeps doing it, you may give
him a chance hoping he changes. But then
you reach a point where you realize
there's nothing you can do to make this
man love you. And because of his
constant neglect and abuse, he kills any
love in your heart. And you walk away,
don't you?
>> Yeah.
>> That's what Jesus will do.
You're my bride. You keep cheating on
me. You keep ignoring me. You keep
running to other lovers. And no matter
what, I keep chasing after you. Give you
a chance after chance after chance after
chance. And the more I show you love and
compassion, the more you despise me, the
more you want to run into the arms of
other lovers. So then it reaches a point
saying, "Well, you know what? I can't
make you love me. And I won't force you
to love me. So I'm going to give you
what you want. I'm going to hand you
over to your lovers."
>> So why do you obey him? Because he's
your husband and he's proven his
faithfulness to you. He is the one
husband who's never hurt you, who's
never humiliated you, who's never
disgraced you, who's never cheated on
you, but has loved you to the point he
died for you and wants the best for you
and wants to crown you and make you as
queen. That's what the Bible says.
>> And so this is how you treat me. This is
how you show your love for me. So then
the Lord says, "All right,
>> I'll hand you over."
In fact, if you want me to show you this
displayed graphically,
graphically displayed, I did a session
on it. And every time I talk about it or
meditate it, it moves me into tears
because I am a sinner who struggles with
the flesh. And I don't want to sin. I
don't want to struggle with the flesh
because I do love him. He is my heart
and I want to obey him, but my filthy
flesh is stronger than me. So, I cry out
to the Lord. Lord, pity me. save me from
my flesh because my body is yours. But
let me show you something graphic. And
this is why we obey him to show him we
because Jesus says, "If you love me,
you'll keep my word." John 14:23. And he
says, "He who hates me will not keep my
word." So I don't care. My wife tells me
she loves me. Why are you cheating on
me? If you love me, why are you out all
night? If you love me, why don't you
want to spend time with me? If you love
me, why is it that you keep putting me
down and insulting me and humiliating me
and comparing me to other lovers? What
kind of love is this?
See, that's what you do to Jesus. See,
even thinking about it, it's moving me
in my spirit because it's hard when I
read these words, but I'm going to read
it for you. I'm going to show you. All
right,
>> okay. Ezekiel 23. It's very graphic, but
you're going to understand why it's
graphic. Because God's people are his
spiritual bride, not physical. He
doesn't come and have sex with us. But
he uses the imagery of physical
marriages to show you how evil it is
when you worship other gods, how evil it
is when you break his commands. Because
he's telling you that's spiritual
adultery. You're cheating on me
spiritually. Here it says it here. James
4:4,
if you love the world that hates God,
God is saying, you're now committing
adultery against me. Here, James 4:4.
You adulteresses,
do you not know that friendship with the
world is enmity toward God? Therefore,
whoever wishes to be a friend of the
world sets himself as enemy God. So, you
see, there's physical adultery and
there's spiritual adultery.
>> Yeah. And God is saying, when you love
the world, you're cheating on me.
Because what's the world done for you
but abuse you, use you, and dump you.
And I've done nothing but prove my love
to you. To the point I, God, became man
and experienced human life in its
fullness and died a human death to pay
your debt to prove I'm in love with you.
What has the world done for you?
>> See right there, it's going to make me
cry. Wooh! It's going to make me cry.
Told you this is very hard for me to
read. Sorry. What has the world done for
you? The world cheats.
>> Yep. Oppresses you, hurts you, abuses
you, dumps you, and you keep running to
the world and running away from me. What
more can I do
to show you I love you?
Therefore repent and return sign of the
Jews that your sins may be wiped out in
order that times of refreshing may come
from presence of the Lord and that he
may send Jesus the Christ appointed for
you. You see what he said? If all of you
repent right now, he's coming down whom
heaven must receive until the period of
restoration of all things about which
God spoke by the mouth of his holy
prophets from ancient time.
But they didn't.
They didn't do it.
Okay. So, why do you obey? Because he's
your husband. And if you don't obey him
and turn from him, what is he going to
do? Hand you a divorce and send you
away.
>> Yeah.
>> So, I I don't know if that answers your
question, but that's why that's the
reason
>> it does. Once you But I don't mean to
cut you off. Once you know God's heart
and you follow him, it's no longer you
don't want to sin because of fear.
It's now you don't want to sin because
you don't want him to cry anymore
because you love him too much.